we both come from these goofy towns in
massachusetts by the way i used to say
i'm from boston yeah until i saw
wahlburgers i've seen every episode of
wahlburgers and i'm like oh my god i am
not from boston like if i ever ran into
any and mark wahlberg was like are you
from boston what pot and be like uh well
uh you know the thing is mark
[Laughter]
i was like this is the most exotic place
i've ever seen that's boston so i'm from
massachusetts yeah exactly i'm from
massachusetts as well i i wall burgers
is i haven't seen every it is a
fascinating show anyway is it still out
there no but you can find it all right
yeah it's like nathan listen
if you take one thing away from this
episode it's watch wahlburgers
so the thing about wahlburgers
anyway but yes alma the mom
thinks donnie wahlberg is like the
biggest star in the world and mark is
still trying to ride his coattails
and like there's no convincing alma like
and mark has this huge chip on his
shoulder he's so competitive he's the
youngest of i think nine or 11 and he's
always trying to best his brother still
on the show he sets up these whole
episodes to show how he can kick his
brother's ass in golf and it's like
you're mark wahlberg but he's just he
won't stop like the show doesn't know
what it's really about they think it's
about a restaurant but it's about these
unbelievable family dynamics and what
power is a a phenomenon like mark
wahlberg
but yes it's always it's always about
the hamburger i i'm here to put a
message in line i'm here to plug a
canceled any show is my point donnie's
bigger for me yeah because i'm a big and
kotb fan so yeah he's where it's at mark
is you know never going to build he's
still in it
yeah so my parents uh you know they've
had the same house in brookline that i
you know basically they took me home as
a baby and it's just the house that i've
been in my whole life my parents have
been there and all my brothers and
sisters and
when new kids on the block was a huge
phenomenon
uh in the 80s
um
late late 80s new kids to us is like
what billy joel is if you're from like
long island for real yeah yeah there's
stories there's legends no for real so
anyway donnie and i think two of them
bought a house in brookline in this nice
part of brookline
and
they had this house
and they lived there and girls used to
hang around outside the house to try and
go see new kids on the block
and when i got my late night show
um
93 there's still a big deal yeah and
a year or two goes by or three
and
i was always kind of wondering huh
they've got
people hanging around outside their
house yeah
does one when are people gonna start
hanging around my parents house i
thought that was gonna happen i thought
it was gonna happen and then once
once
there was some
like so you're hanging around outside
just how it comes back there were some t
there were two teenagers hanging outside
our house
and my parents told me there's some
people here that want to come to say hi
to you and i went well i guess you know
and i went out and they said yeah we
were hanging outside the new kids on the
block house for a long time and they
didn't come out
so we got really bored and came over
here
we got their left over
they literally like oh we didn't even
need you to come out well i'm here you
want some pictures you want some
pictures no we're good
do you know how we could get into the
new kids house
i really don't but i could take you guys
out to lunch
no we've eaten
and we're lactose intolerant oh
do you want to come back later no
we're good
conan invite them in no they don't want
to come in
they want to hang around the new kids on
the block house
in 99 in 99 yeah yeah
um
anyway that's my story and uh tells you
where i'm coming from